voilà tout est fermé comme ça tu n'auras
pas trop de travail il te suffit de bien
veiller à ce que les enfants ne se fasse
pas mal et à faire attention parce que
personne ne s'approche trop du kiosque
ou des ballons de françois c'est compris
pour tu écoutes ne manquent pas des
facteurs lui au moins c'est un homme
très consciencieux dans son travail
je m'en fiche parce que je ne sais même
pas ce que ça veut dire voyons casimir
ce n'est pas parce qu'on ne comprend pas
quelque chose qu'il faut s'en moquer au
contraire essayer d'apprendre ce que
l'on ne sait pas être très consciencieux
par exemple cela veut dire faire ce que
l'on fait très bien le plus sérieusement
du monde
ah bon alors je te promets d'être le
gardien le plus consciencieux du monde
situé le gardien le plus consciencieux
de l'île aux enfants ce sera déjà
formidable allez il faut que je te
quitte
je vais rejoindre françois qui doivent
aider à repeindre les volets de ma
maison
au revoir au revoir julie rey soit
tranquille il ne se passera rien j'en
suis sûr oui
wahaha
oh la la quoi qu avez vous fait vous
faire rire on parce que vous êtes
ridicules mais alors tellement ridicule
aa noire et dit comment je ne vois
vraiment pas pourquoi
oh vous est maigre mais alors tellement
maigre mais qu'est ce que vous faites
ici vous ne vous ne vais pas acheter la
allait très bien je pars j'aurais voulu
simplement vous poser une question
bon mais alors une folle ne seriez-vous
pas le grand le célèbre casino las le
célèbre casimir
oui c'est moi pourquoi est-ce donc droit
à une deuxième question
bon d'accord n'aimeriez vous pas vivre
dans une île encore plus belle
et devenir encore plus célèbres au mais
je suis très bien ici je ne veux pas
aller dans une autre il n'est pas ce que
je voulais dire en vérité boisrobert et
or ar je vous propose de faire de l'île
aux enfants
l'île la plus belle du monde c'est déjà
la plus virile du monde
vous avez raison je viens de l'habilité
votre il est très très belle mais on
pourrait y apporter certaines
modifications qui la rendrait plus
agréable à vivre
romont je la trouve très agréable telle
qu'elle est si vous ne vous y plaisait
pas vous n'êtes pas obligés de rester à
d'ailleurs vous ne vais pas rester là à
la route était très bien je m'en vais
j'aurais voulu pourtant vous donner un
exemple de modifications qui vous aurait
transformé la vie à bout pas moi à moins
bon qu'attendu puisque vous voulez que
je m'en aille le monde attendait à
monsieur monsieur 1re temps au temps je
voudrais que vous me donniez cet exemple
très bien j'ai obéi il s'agit d'une
usine de gloubiboulga surgelés avec
distributeurs automatiques en petits
pots ou encore nos eaux du gloubiboulga
glacé encorner et vous en aurez être
délicieux
vous en aurez tant que vous voudrez pas
bon et alors où comptez-vous construire
cette usine
et bien c'est très simple avec des
bulldozer on abat les arbres de petit
bois à abattre le petit bois qui hélas
ne penser qu'à vous gloubiboulga glace
et ce sera délicieux
c'est vrai ça demande à certains
sacrifices
or on ne peut pas tout avoir très juste
de ce quasiment oui d'ailleurs vous
savez au bout de quelques semaines vous
n'entendrez plus les bruits de lusine
les bruits mais julien a horreur du
bruit à vous avez bien raison de penser
à votre ami mademoiselle julie
je vais pouvoir faire son bonheur elle
aussi a elle aussi
et comment alors elle vit en permanence
dans son kiosque
eh bien elle pourra dormir tard le matin
aller à la plage toute la journée au
faire de grands voyages au pays comment
allez-vous faire alors
eh bien je remplace que son vieux
kiosque branlant par un magnifique
kiosques en béton armé de quatre étages
avec 150 distributeurs automatiques de
boissons de jouets et de cadeaux il
suffit de mettre une pièce pour avoir ce
que l'on désigne mais c'est formidable
et un des distributeurs art alors je ne
verrai pas joli tous les jours ne soyez
pas égoïste ces sons d'odeurs qui compte
c'est vrai
ouais et et françois alors un front soit
je vais pouvoir faire son bonheur aussi
ah bon je suis très content
j'installerai une machine qui gonflera
10 ballons par seconde et une autre qui
fera affaire 25 jeux par jour aux
enfants fare loi aura tout le temps
d'étudier tranquillement bon et alors
quand allez-vous pouvoir commencer tout
ça et bien dès que vous aurez signé ce
petit papier pour me donner
l'autorisation de commencer comme moi je
peux décider de toutes ces choses là
mais oui mais oui je viens de vérifier
dans le livre de l'île aux enfants et
j'ai découvert une vieille loi où tout
le monde avait oublié et qui dit que le
dernier descendant de casimir premier
roi de casimir us peut prendre toutes
les décisions qui lui semblent bonnes
pour l'île aux enfants de n'est signé
merci et que tournez vous et baissez
vous que je puisse la signer sur votre
dos volontiers pour une signature hausse
historique mais monsieur retors que
veulent dire ces phrases écrit en tout
petit je n'arrive même pas à aller lire
le ce n'est rien ce sont des formules
obligatoire sans importance signera à
draper lumbago si ce sont des formules
sans importance est différent monsieur
retors qui at il encore à il n'ya plus
d'encre dans votre stylo ce type ne
m'avait pas et non je n'en ai pas
il est le coeur ce que de julie est
fermé
quel mal fidèles mal son os voilà
monsieur 10 nov
c'est très bien vous savez il ya
toujours un stylo sur lui monsieur on
est sauvé écoutez écoutez je ne peux pas
rester signait ce petit papier ce soir
chez vous je passerai chercher demain
matin et non par la personne ne l'oublié
pas à personne oui c'est une surprise à
mai mais monsieur retour au revoir à
demain aux nouvelles normes en casimir
ah oui enfin non pour écoutez je ne
devrais pas vous en parler parce que
c'est une surprise mais je veux signer
un contrat qui va rendre tous les
habitants de l'île heureux bon mais
c'est passionnant cette voie la houle ou
là ou là là quelle horreur mais c'est
affreux
mais que se passe-t-il bondissent nab
enfin casino tu allais faire notre
malheur à nous tous et non votre bonheur
as tu seulement lui ces quelques lignes
écrites en tout petit lettres là là non
ça monsieur retour m'a dit que c'était
des petites formules sans important oui
eh bien écoutez formule sans importance
après la signature de ce contrat
françois julie le facteur monsieur du
snob et casimir devront quitter l'île
aux enfants pour toujours quoi mais
c'est vraiment ce qui est écrit est
exactement mais alors ce monsieur retour
c'est un bandit
disons que c'est un homme d'affaires pas
très honnête au romero qu'est ce que je
vais faire quand il va revenir demain et
bien écoutez semir nous allons être là
tous les deux à l'attendre
merci monsieur disent non merci il va
voir ce retour au il va voir